yo what's up guys prestige here and I
have a very interesting survive I
haven't seen free you gotta see you know
you spawned enough force they might not
think this is to survive violently but
it's interpreting different twists and
see it's not like you're limited for
wood however I still in think it's a
great seed the seed aim is art Oh mix a
RT 0 m IX now it's actually a seed for
the pc and it's supposed to be a jungle
island which would be a lot cooler than
a forest but they don't have jungles and
uh oh they don't have jungles in the
wolf kill the sheet that will then have
jungles and xbox so the best i can do is
a force now if you put this in once they
come out the jungle so we get a jungle
now uh something that I found really
cool about this because of the spawning
physics minecraft all of the animals
you've ever come across in the world are
right here on this island they spawn on
you you have just tons of piggies pairs
amount philippine you tons of pigs and
cows I like this stuff okay Camille pork
chops Canyon for truck but also there's
some other features in this map that are
really cool so if i go over here and
grab my map you can go check them out
you can basically go on throughout this
stuff you can go anywhere that you want
to in this map and again the server the
seed and you will be able to do survival
island like I go back over here you see
we have a crazy island this will be more
survival island because there's only
about four trees and there's also like a
snow biome raining switch so this is
definitely this will make for some epic
survival on and even on the first island
you can do a lot more because you have
so much more would eat right off the bat
or at the start you can google out like
crazier house now they're also mushroom
biome scattered throughout here and just
other ones like you see this is one chai
mother tree I think that's about it
there's some mushroom biome here so you
can spawn some mushrooms and like even
right here this will be a great survival
I on T so this map kind of has like 25
survival islands for you too
from and i would like to start so what
I'll in the video i hope you guys
enjoyed this my name is prestige if you
did leave it a like that's it helps a
lot it really does help Ally believe me
if you guys leave a like so please do
that and if you're new subscribe for
more of the Minecraft probably some more
seed showcase is probably some more
gameplay some promise more hair brown
survivals you guys seem to love that so
all go and pieces